[Musique]
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir bienvenue
dans votre émission débat sur 7,8 tv
stupéfaction pour les uns ou divine
surprise pour les autres samedi soir le
premier ministre edouard philippe a pris
tout le monde de court en annonçant le
retrait de la candidature française pour
l'organisation de l'exposition
universelle 2025
quelles sont les conséquences de ce
retrait ces décisions métal en péril à
la construction de la ligne 18 du grand
paris express pas en débattre
j'accueille autour de moi grégoire de
lasteyrie pont soir vous êtes ce
les républicains de pas d eau qui se
trouve sur plateau de saclay vous êtes
est également conseiller régional et
vous êtes ici en qualité de président de
l'union des élus pour la ligne 18 ans
faisait vous j'accueille également
monsieur laurent legendre bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes président de
l'association inter entreprises delta
sky
vous voulez en fait un meilleur
accroissement de l'économie de saint
quentin en yvelines est également plus
de transports en commun sur ce
territoire bénéfice des salariés de nos
entreprises
à côté des vosges heigl j'accueille
également monsieur marc jakim bonsoir en
soit vous êtes membre du collectif
urgence saclay et vous vous opposez
notamment à l'expo universelle mais
également la construction de la ligne 18
oui expliquerai pourquoi tout à l'heure
alors c'est le slogan de cette
exposition était à science a partagé la
place nette à protéger cette exposition
n'aura pas lieu finalement sur le
plateau de saclay qui laisse derrière
lui beaucoup de projets en suspens
notamment la construction d'un
planétarium notamment aussi la
conversion des pavillons en logements
étudiants mais également en incubateur
de start up mais aussi la promesse de
création de 160 me emploie aujourd'hui
monsieur grégoire de lasteyrie où en
sommes-nous sur ses promesses qu'est-ce
qu'il va sortir de terre parce que tout
est annulé
alors il ya plusieurs choses le plateau
de saclay est un projet qui date d'il ya
10 ans où on cherche à créer un cluster
de rayonnement international où on
accueillera
soixante mille étudiants dix mille
enseignants chercheurs des grosses
entreprises des grands noms de la
recherche privée comme publique donc le
projet du plateau de saclay il existe
depuis dix ans depuis quelques temps il
y avait un projet de candidature à
l'exposition universelle pour faire le
projet dont vous avez parlé à l'instant
avec des activités spécifiques
ce projet là le premier ministre l'a
annoncé samedi soir a clairement du pont
dans la ligne verra le raja le jour
c'est à dire que le planétarium sera
évidemment pas construit le village
universelle qui devait accueillir les
pavillons du monde entier et est recyclé
ensuite en résidence étudiante pour des
pays du monde entier pas ne pourra pas
voir le jour parce qu'il n'aura pas les
financements des différents pays étant
donné qu aura pas de pavillon des
différents pays donc évidemment un
incubateur n'ont plus de logement
étudiant sur cette partie là où devait
se construire est spécifiquement
construit pour l'exposition universelle
ne le sera pas l'incubateur
d'entreprise et qui est un projet
physiquement sur palaiseau aujourd'hui
est toujours prévu parce que il existait
avant le projet d'exposition universelle
le projet de saclay continue à vivre au
delà du projet d'exposition universelle
d'accord donc on fait une croix sur ont
fait une croix clairement sur le
planétarium et ont fait une croix sur
tous les équipements qu'il y avait
autour d'accords et pour vous est ce que
c'est une
est-ce que ça a un impact notamment sur
les économies sur les entreprises de
saint quentin en yvelines cette annonce
il ya forcément un impact sur l'activité
des entreprises notamment du bâtiment
qui était censée construire ces
équipements il ya un impact également
pour les entreprises dans le domaine du
tourisme qui l attendait des retombées
avec un nombre de visiteurs important
dans cette un projet sur lequel on doit
tirer un trait il est abandonné
on espère que le projet de paris saclay
lui n'en pâtira pas et que
indépendamment de ce projet d'exposition
universelle maintiendra le même rythme
de construction et de développement de
ce projet paris saclay des pertes
d'argent notamment pour le btp mais pour
l'instant rien de gravissime notamment
pour le tourisme
tant qu'un projet n'est pas signée n'est
pas finalisé de toute façon on tire des
plans sur la comète la décision ait été
prise de l'arrêté
maintenant on se tourne vers des projets
qui veut n'étaient pas des projets
éphémères
le projet paris saclay est un projet
pérenne
que qui a besoin d'être accélérée hier
les voeux de l'établissement public
paris saclay
a été répété le besoin de créer ce
cluster qui sera un des huit cluster
mondiaux pour la recherche de locaux
d'accord donc pour vous ça change rien
mais pour voir ce que vous voyez ça
comme une victoire notamment alors que
vous avez utilisé avant le mot origines
oui enfin ça réjouit certains quelque
chose comme ça alors nous on se réjouit
pas de la déception des autres c'est pas
ça mais c'est un soulagement c'est un
soulagement parce que pour nous vous
avez un autre moi quel mot slogan en
donnant le titre de l'expo universelle a
connaissance à partager la planète à
protéger et nous en tant que militant
écologiste on voit pas du tout que
bétonné et faire du tourisme de masse en
fait que parler monsieur c'est un
quelconque rapport avec la protection de
la planète
c'est exactement le contraire selon
notre point de vue donc encore lui on
est soulagé soulagé de voir son léger
mais provisoirement puisqu'il ya
d'autres projets en cours d'urbanisation
sur le plateau vous allez très menaçant
aussi d'accord nous allait revenir tout
à l'heure vous voulez jeter quelque
chose agir à ce que dit monsieur g
khimki qui étaient inquiets du fait que
l'exposition universelle puisse bétonner
le plateau de saclay les élus qui
s'étaient engagés à soutenir on avait
posé plusieurs lignes rouges sur le
projet d'exposition universelle
la première d une rouge qu'on avait posé
en tout cas moi j'avais dis très
clairement
c'était que le projet du plateau de
saclay existait il y avait des terres
qui avait décidé d'être protégés au
titre de terres agricoles forestières ou
naturels 2700 hectares et ça avait été
la contrepartie et dix ans quand on
avait décidé de créer le plateau de
saclay et donc on avait dit voici les
terres qui seront totalement intouchable
et voici les terres qui seront urbanisés
ou urbanisable et ils nous on avait dit
le contexte de l'exposition universelle
doit être strictement conscrits à
l'intérieur des terres qui sont déjà
urbanisables il était hors de question
pour nous qu'on puisse grignoté 1 mètre
carré de terre naturelle forestières ou
agricole pour pouvoir permettre le
le projet d'exposition universelle pour
excepté allemande a en fait donc donc on
maintenait la densification urbaine à
l'intérieur des terres qui avait déjà
été fléchés comme devant participer au
développement du cluster mais bien sûr
on était très nombreux à dire on ne
souhaite pas attaquer les terres
agricoles du plateau qui sont fertiles
les terres forestières qui sont aussi
qui font partie de l'attractivité de ce
territoire pour les populations qui y
vivent
c'était des sujets qui étaient et c'est
une ligne rouge pour nous notamment
autour de cette annulation de retrait de
la candidature pour l'exposition
universelle il ya une autre question qui
a beaucoup inquiété outre notamment
cette annulation c'est notamment la
question du chantier de la ligne 18 sur
ce terrain-là mardi dernier le premier
ministre avait déclaré vouloir maintenir
ce projet donc pour répondre aux
inquiétudes notamment des élus notamment
de l'université aussi qu'il veut
absolument cette ligne 18
cependant il a dit qu'il voulait aussi
il avait aussi annoncé le lancement
d'une période de consultation et des
changes est ce que pour vous c'est une
façon de noyer le poisson de retarder
justement la mise en chantier de cette
ligne alors en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est le renoncement de l'exposition
universelle ne devrait pas caché le
renoncement à la ligne 18
la ligne 18 pourquoi est-ce qu'il ya ce
projet pareil depuis une dizaine
d'années dans les cartons de créer un
métro qui reliera orly au plateau de
saclay en terminant à versailles
chantiers et donc qui serait un des
barreaux du grand paris express
parce que justement lorsque l'état a
décidé de construire le cluster de
saclay donc qui je le rappel doit
concentrer 15% de la recherche française
et être à un cluster à dimension
internationale comme il y en a quelques
autres quelques unités ailleurs dans le
dans le monde
bah un tel projet ne peut être que
correctement desservi par un transport
par un moyen de transport fiable rapide
et qui permet d'éviter les bouchons de
l'ile-de-france que ça veut dire que là
vous êtes vous n'êtes pas inquiété vous
n'êtes pas un cadeau tendance à tendance
qui j'ai eu lieu il y aura une
consultation et des échanges ont
peut-être une modification justement je
touche ce qui a été fait jusqu'à présent
oui la consultation ne remet pas en
cause le projet le tracé a été validé le
risque que l'on peut voir les
entreprises
ils sont prêtres sont assez inquiètes
sur le sujet c'est le délai dans lequel
va être réalisé ce projet le projet de
paris saclay est un projet ambitieux qui
est un projet de développement
économique avant tout qui doit aider à
la compétitivité de nos entreprises
grâce à l'innovation qui est issu de ce
cluster où on mélange des laboratoires
de recherche des grandes écoles de la
matière grise à une échelle qui est
unique en pays et on a besoin
de cette ligne 18 pour desservir cette
zone et la relier avec les zones
d'activités saint quentin en yvelines
concentre 140 mille emplois nous avons
des parmi les plus grandes entreprises
entre renault bouygues les entreprises
de l'aéronautique
vous avez des les plus grandes filières
du pays qui sont représentées sur ce
territoire et on a besoin de cette
jonction faire venir des ingénieurs
rapidement pendant leur stage pouvoir
travailler faire des réunions avec les
centres de recherche tout ça c'est très
important
internet existent mais ne fait pas tout
et on a besoin d'un moyen de transport
structures et vous que pensez-vous
notamment de set peut-être main tendue
notamment pour une meilleure
concertation consultations et des
échanges sociaux nous paraît très
indispensable puisque sur la ligne 18
bon j'aurais aimé répondre un petit peu
sur la zone de protection agricole donc
monsieur l'asturien parler mais bon pour
vous répondre sur la ligne 18 le fait
que les projets soient remis à plat
alors qu'il ya eu des rapports le
rapport aux années en 2012
le rapport de la du commissariat général
à l'investissement 2015 qui remettent en
cause quand même l'utilité de cette
ligne surdimensionné qui était
paradoxalement un petit peu su sous
dimensionné si on attendait 40 millions
de visiteurs en six mois pour
l'exposition universelle ce qu'ils aient
200 milles par jour c'est une une ligne
de métro lourds comme la ligne 18 telle
qu'elle est envisagée
sept cent mille cent mille voyageurs
jour donc c'est quand même énorme c'est
beaucoup enfin c'est très
surdimensionnées par rapport aux besoins
actuels du plateau qui rappelons le quai
entouré de la ligue b au sud de l'insee
au nord et qui a surtout besoin de
liaison nord-sud en particulier depuis
les vallées sage assad en commun qui
soient fiables
c'est à dire que pour vous le plateau de
saclay n'a pas besoin d'un super m mais
on en ont au contraire
non au contraire c'est une menace en
fait le supermétro c'est l'urbanisation
à outrance maximale du plateau et la z
hénaff la zone de protection naturelle
forestières agricoles n'y résistera pas
d'ailleurs il ya déjà des manipulations
sur le
le cadastre dans le cadre de une enquête
publique sur le tracé sur les
expropriations lily allen 18 et on voit
que par rapport au décret de la z hénaff
déjà les parcelles sont modifiées par
rapport au décret donc il ya eu déjà des
petits arrangements qui commence à
grignoter
dès aujourd'hui la z pena ses
impressionnants jeux mais je la rends
moi j'ai une question quand même parce
que j'entends parler de super métro
c'est quoi un super métro moi je connais
le métro c'est un métro un métro
automatique donc c'est la ligne une
qu'on a qui traverse paris
c'est la ligne 14 mai c'est un métro on
parle d'un transport en commun classique
tueur quelque chose qui me surprend
terriblement il ya une exception
territoriales sur le plateau de saclay
partout en france c'est le seul
territoire où les mouvements écologistes
sont en défaveur des transports en
commun on n'a pas les faveurs des
dosettes en défaveur des transports en
commun on est sur une zone sur lequel le
transport routier totalement saturée sur
lequel les rer
ça fait 30 ans 40 ans qui est un sous
investissement chronique très graves sur
les rer avec valérie pécresse on a lancé
un programme d'investissements lourds
qui portera ses fruits mais kilomètres
quelques années parce qu'évidemment
régénérer un réseau de cette taille là
ça prend du temps
et évidemment on a
on a la possibilité d'avoir un cluster
qui se construit autour d'une colonne
vertébrale qui est la ligne 18 cette
colonne vertébrale elle est essentielle
ça a été redit récemment dans une lettre
ouverte au président la république en
début de semaine par sept grands
scientifiques médaille fields
prix nobel et autres dont une
scientifique bien connu qui est qui qui
agit au sein du giec
donc pour lequel les questions
environnementales sont évidents
évidemment primordial métro à ce seul et
c'est soit un métro soit un but sain
c'est l'un ou l'autre quand même
rapidement on arrive au bout en bout des
différentes possibilités qui existent et
et les bus est ce qu'il ya aujourd'hui
sur le plateau de saclay moi je vous
invite à venir un matin à 7h30 et 8h à
8h30 pour voir dans quel état sont nos
bus ils sont totalement surchargé c'est
déjà des bus double articulé et un bus
aujourd'hui ça roule pas à l'électrique
c'est pas vrai ça pollue ça crée des
parties pas des particules fines ce qui
évidemment un métro permet d'éviter donc
un les prétentions en commun c'est le
deal est gênante et des élus locaux de
changer d'avoir des bus électriques ou
d'avoir d'autres et monsieur répondre et
moi mais là aujourd'hui surtout en prime
de l'industrie on peut pas faire des
gros bus lourd avec ce débile acquis
soit électrique parce qu'on n'a pas les
batteries pour donc là leur sujet
électrique il à différents sports
capacitaire la prévision de trafic qui
ont été faites à l'origine par le stif
ya une dizaine d'années pour la ligne 18
sont probablement très sous-évalué on a
refait avec saint quentin en yvelines
un modèle qui intègre
toutes les spécificités de la seconde
couronne parisienne en étant des
parkings de rabattement mettant du
covoiturage et en mettant les liens qui
peut y avoir avec certaines 18 et on
arrive à des estimations de trafic qui
sont 50% plus élevé que les estimations
qui avaient été faites initialement
pourtant vous vous trouvez un autre chef
on commence à ce que je sais pas bon
donc il ya des rapports d'experts on
sort d'autres chiffres moi je veux bien
je suis pas d'ailleurs le spécialiste de
la question est simplement dans les
rapports il est mentionné que un
cinquième des gens qui travaillent sur
le plateau viennent du sud
enfin viennent par l'est du plateau du
sud de paris donc depuis ma 6e 5e la
majorité des gens viennent des villes
alentours des vallées et là il faut il
faut des transports transversaux qui
fonctionne bien alors le site en le
transport en site propre par exemple est
une très bonne chose
c'était déjà saturé hui il est saturé
non c'est pas ce que disent les usagers
en fait les usagers ne se plaignent pas
aux heures de pointe il ya des bus
articulations mais c'est dans les forums
de ne pas vous laisser dire ça mais j'ai
imaginé des gens qui prennent des
voiries des élections nature mais j'ai
pas saturer les gens se plaignent pas
aux heures de pointe par contre ils se
plaignent ils pas dire ça banalise les
vois je vous invite demain matin
monsieur je vous donne une feuille je
suis j'ai appris je vais avec damas où
les gens avec les jours des gens ne
peuvent pas monter dans le bus ils
doivent attendre le bus d'après d'aller
au départ les trois minutes il y en a
déjà un tous les trois minutes on a
renforcé en août dernier pour justement
passé de 1 toutes les quatre minutes un
toutes les trois minutes
on a renforcé fin août dernier avec le
stif et pour autant ça continue à ne pas
passer les gens continuent à asson
plaignent que en dehors des heures de
pointe effectivement là il ya des
besoins criants du
grande conséquence et puis il ya aussi
des dysfonctionnements et moi j'ai un
exemple de dysfonctionnement d'un
transport en commun qui qui dépendent
des élus locaux puisque c'est la ligne
de bus est celle là elle par delà de la
gare d'orsay et le monde sur le plateau
en traversant la l'université paris sud
est puis elle arrive sur le plateau du
moulon qui est des grands pôles de paris
saclay dans grosso modo faut revoir
notamment mais là il ya des tice a dit
que c'est une catastrophe parce que
c'est pas fiable il ya des horaires il
ya des bus qui passent pas les gens
attendent une de mieux enfin voilà il ya
même des messages en anglais il y en a
même un terroriste notamment sur notre
sujet n'ont qu'à des gens qui aient le
temps de des transports actuels sont pas
fiables faut commencer par assad
je suis content qu'on soit vraiment
maintenant on n'est pas d'accord parce
que c'est aujourd'hui le métro il
viendra taris et c'est aujourd'hui
ouais moi je fais partie d'année d'un
établissement qui va déménager dans un
en 2019
donc pendant alors le métro c koi 2024
donc pendant cinq ans ça va être la
galère pendant cinq ans il va falloir
trouver des solutions palliatives je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
simplement irradiâtes il ya deux sujets
sains il va falloir gérer la période
jusqu'à l'arrivée du métro et icsa sera
jusqu'en 2024 vous avez raison ça sera
déjà très très long et rude à 2024 il
faut le métro mais on n'a pas demandé
des jeunes ne savent pas du tout sûr sur
le délai de donner un quatre pages qu'il
ya quelques semaines la cour des comptes
ça a eu un a publié un rapport au
vitriol contre notamment la gestion
financière en parlant de dérapages
si je suis totalement les chiffres il
disait qu' on avait un coût prévisionnel
pour cette ligne 2 en 2010 et 18
milliards d'euros pour ceux qui roulent
encore l'ensemble des lignes
d'aucune façon c'est un impact haussier
sur cette ligne a malheureusement mais
ensuite aujourd'hui on est à trente cinq
35 milliards d'euros soit presque le
double
in fine et est ce que cette ligne va
paraître ou pas on a déjà eu des bruits
notamment de gouvernement qui disait
peut-être qu'on va plutôt mettre des bus
souvent téléphérique ou des choses tout
à fait différentes
dans ce cas vous partez d'un principe
comme toi il y aura bien un match ont
effectué les cours de la nuit sauf
qu'aujourd'hui ce que dit la cour des
comptes est intéressant il faut tout
lire sur ce que dit la cour des comptes
la cour des comptes a laissé un rapport
sur paris saclay en janvier 2010 est
donc il ya moins d'un an
et dans ce rapport la laque ou et la
cour des comptes disait paris-saclay sa
vie vote et ça ne marche pas encore à
son plein potentiel
parce qu'il n'ya pas le métro le métro
arrive en 2024 et c'est déjà très tard
ça c'est la cour des comptes qui le dit
hein aujourd'hui la cour des comptes
quand elle refait son rapport elle parle
de la gestion financière de la société
du grand paris
elle ne parle pas des différents kling
ne se prononce pas sur l'opportunité de
telle ou telle ligne elle dit il ya un
dérapage global de 20 milliards d'euros
elle renvoie d'ailleurs l'état à ses
responsabilités en disant c'est pas que
de la faute de la deûle de la société du
grand paris qui a eu un décalage mais
c'est aussi la faute de l'état qui n'a
pas joué son rôle de contrôle ou qui a
peut-être fait des opérations financées
avec la cité du grand paris que l'état
n'aurait pas dû faire donc un moment il
faut aussi que l'état assume ses
responsabilités et maintenant si on
regarde concrètement de combien on parle
pour la ligne 18 la ligne 18 d'orly au
plateau de saclay ces deux milliards
d'euros donc c'est vrai la société du
grand paris a eu un dérapage de plus de
20 milliards d'euros qui fait quasiment
38 milliard d'euros sur ses coûts
actuels mais le
la ligne le premier segment la ligne 18
a quasiment pas dérapé parce que sur 2
milliard d'euros on se rend compte que
c'est des chiffres qui sont pas du tout
à la même échelle et vous ne croyez pas
notamment que cet appel du premier
ministre à plus de consultations et des
changes n'est pas une manière justement
de retarder c'est un risque et si
richard jacques seraient les
conséquences notamment les conséquences
elle serait terrible c'est un coup
d'arrêt au projet d'éoliennes
paris-saclay vous pouvez pas de
développer un cluster d'envergure
internationale sans mettre en place les
transports en commun les transports en
commun qu'ils desservent
on est à saint-quentin ici existe depuis
40 ans depuis 40 ans il n'y a pas eu de
nouveaux développements donc vous pouvez
pas apporter du développement vous allez
mettre des écoles des laboratoires de
recherche sans transport qui vont
vivoter pendant des années et vous ne
vous n'arriverez pas à enclencher
derrière le développement économique
nécessaire pour faire une zone homogène
qui apporte le le développement prévu
parce question mais pourtant il ya aussi
je sais pas si il ya notre dame des
landes notamment qui a été arrêté parce
qu'il n'avait pas suffisamment de
concertation par rapport à la population
locale il ya un début de contestation
but depuis notre dame des landes c'est
un sujet sur lequel il s'est jamais rien
passé là depuis dix ans sur le plateau
de saclay c'est des milliards d'euros
que l'état investit free à palaiseau edf
a investi 400 millions d'euros qui le
vit à gol qui ont bien sûr pas les eaux
arrivent et donc là quelque part on est
sur un coup parti ça fait dix ans que
trois prisons la république successifs
sont venus à palaiseau et sur le plateau
de saclay confirmé le projet du cluster
pour vous donc ça se feront l'actuel
président de la république
donc moi je ne dis pas que j'ai pas de
doute je dis simplement que si jamais
l'état devait swan une hélène 18 soit la
décaler dans le temps l'état tuerait
dans l'oeuf
enfin pas dans l'oeuf mais la nature est
en l'état le projet du cluster et ce
serait très grave parce que ça veut dire
que c'est plusieurs milliards d'euros
dépensés depuis disons pour localiser la
recherche française à un endroit et et
la r&d qui va autour que l'on jetterait
par la fenêtre
donc moi je sensibilisera le premier
ministre je vais
redit après midi à sa convocation avec
les autres élus du grand paris express
pour dire attention on a on va envoyer
un très mauvais signal à la recherche et
plus généralement à l'industrie
française comme et pourtant il ya aussi
un point de friction notamment qui est
le viaduc aérien qui fait grincer des
dents notamment en plus des associations
écologistes il ya aussi le maire de
magny les hameaux qui dit qu'il n'est
pas d'accord avec ce tracé là que cette
race et perturbent notamment va la vie
des riverains et après tout notre
activité de ce territoire là ceux ci la
qualité de vie aussi les grands les
princesses et on est dans une démocratie
et heureusement que les uns et les
autres peuvent avoir des avis différents
sur un projet et moi je comprends la
position du maire de magny les hameaux
qui ne souhaitent pas d'avoir un métro
aérien parce que lui il ne voit pas tout
de suite un intérêt direct pour son
territoire c'est un projet d'intérêt
général on a parlé notamment de ses
inconvénients puisque vous vous partagez
notamment 7,7 points que moi je voudrais
aussi parler encore un peu des
alternatives on n'a pas du tout parlé
des téléphériques vous avez invité dans
ce débat et le mois dernier ou en
novembre
un représentant de l'association colosse
moi j'invite les gens à les voir aller
sur le site de l'association colosse
point info où ils verront comme quoi les
des solutions télé ferrer qui
permettrait donc les liaisons vals et
plateaux sont très efficaces si on a un
peu partout dans le monde et ça marche
très bien et ce sera très adapté au
plateau dont il n'y a pas besoin
la solution unique métro line 18
c'est faux déjà les champs d'immenses
est surdimensionné il ya des
alternatives sérieuses bon et la cession
de ciel ouvert à d'autres
un autre tracé ou à déménager bien sûr
non mais nous nous enfin bon
effectivement c'est un projet paris
saclay le déménagement des instituts de
recherche ça a commencé il ya dix ans en
réalité ça commence et même bien avant
puisque il ya eu le rapport christian
blanc en 2005 qui lui prévoyait une
urbanisation vraiment massif du plateau
est donc la zp hénaff la zone de
protection naturelle forestière agricole
de 1300 hectares elecam liés et les
quand même dû à la au combat au combat
des décès des associations
environnementales locales qui ont qui
ont réussi à obtenir cela aujourd'hui
les maires se présente comme si c'était
grâce à eux que ça a été acquis mais non
c'est ça a été acquis grâce à la
mobilisation des citoyens des
associations de défense de
l'environnement donc ça il faut quand
même laisser le monopole de rien du tout
monsieur vous savez mais mais mais pour
vous mettre au niveau des entreprises
est ce qu'une alternative c'est quelque
chose qui est ouvert sur la table
pouvait entendre notamment une
alternative ne pourra pas être aussi
capacité à que le métro est on est on
les prévisions de trafic que l'on a
montre que le métro est nécessaire 2024
c'est un objectif qui est déjà très
lointain pour nous aider saint quentin
en yvelines par exemple dans les projets
ne peut être desservi contenu trentels
projet initial on pense qu'il ya même
possibilité d'utiliser cette ce tracé
est rien qui est très rapide à
construire puisque vous pouvez
construire les tronçons parallèle c'est
beaucoup plus rapide qu un tunnelier
c'est une solution pour les publi t on
réfléchis avec la société du grand paris
il ya même des solutions techniques pour
desservir saint quentin en yvelines
six ans plus tôt et desservir dès 2024
grâce au prolongement de la partie
aérienne jusqu'à saint quentin en 2024
et vous que souhaitez-vous notamment
pour qu'ils reviennent sur cette liaison
une minute ça m'a presque à la fin de la
mission qu'une minute sur l'a6 l'a10 ont
18 bat comme je vous ai dit nous notre
association l'urgence saclay en
particulier grâce à à collo cela qu'il
ya vraiment documenté de manière très
sérieuse toutes les alternatives
on espère que vous avez cité notre-dame
des landes un moment l'état a regardé
les deux solutions les deux alternatives
en place et il a pris la plus
raisonnable donc on espère que des gens
vont arrêter avec le dogme de 2,7 une 18
et puis regardez les alternatives qui
sont rapidement possible minutes pour
conclure notamment sur l'avenir de sa
seule ligne 18,2 à vrai dire la ligne 18
elle n'est pas exclusive des bus elle
n'est pas exclusive des téléphériques je
connais bien les sujets parce que je
connais bien l'association colosse je
travaille régulièrement avec eux et
effectivement les téléphériques sont
aussi utiles d'ailleurs c'est pas les
mêmes financeurs mais on aura besoin de
téléphérique à court terme on a besoin
d'un renfort de bus encore mais tout
cela n'aura pas vous le dit très bien
monsieur 1
la couverture complète de la capacité
pour desservir le plateau donc on a
aussi besoin de cette ligne de métro
c'est ce que nous les élus on va
continuer à défendre avec nombre
d'usagers du plateau et c'est la
condition sine qua none pour que le
projet de saclay continue à se
développer et et saclay qui réussissent
et des emplois en france
partout parce que c'est nos entreprises
qui vont être plus compétitifs grâce à
la r&d qui sera inventé à saclay et
c'est des points de croissance pour
l'économie et donc c'est la
redistribution des chats sur tout le
territoire
c'est des objectifs je crois sur
lesquels on peut qu'être tous d'accord
dans son ensemble merci à vous tous
d'avoir accepté de participer à ce débat
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous tous d'avoir participé encore une
fois vous pouvez voir et revoir cette
émission sur notre site internet
passer une agréable journée est née la
semaine prochaine
[Musique]